now
on that little transition i mean
how do you make the transition work is
uh is this where driver sensing
comes in like how do you make the
because you said 100 miles
like is is there some
sort of human factor psychology thing
where people start to over trust the
system all those kinds of
effects once it gets better and better
and better and better they get lazier
and lazier and lazier
is that like how do you get that
transition right first off our
monitoring is already adaptive
uh our monitoring is already seen
adaptive driver monitoring
is this the camera that's looking at the
driver you have an infrared camera
in the our policy for
how we enforce the driver monitoring is
scene adaptive what does that mean
well for example in one of the extreme
cases um
if you uh if the car is not moving we do
not
uh actively enforced driver monitor
right
if you are going through a uh like a 45
mile an hour road with lights
um and stop signs and potentially
pedestrians we enforce a very tight
driver monitoring policy
if you are alone on a perfectly straight
highway
um and this is it's all machine learning
none of that is hand coded
actually the stop is hand coded but so
there's some kind of machine learning
estimation of risk yeah i mean i've
always been a huge fan of that
that that's uh because it's difficult to
do
every step into that direction
is a worthwhile stop to take it might be
difficult to do really well like us
humans are able to
estimate risk pretty damn well whatever
the hell that is
that feels like one of the nice features
of us humans
uh because like we humans are really
good drivers when we're really like
tuned in and we're good at estimating
risk like
when are we supposed to be tuned in yeah
and
you know people are like oh well you
know why would you ever make the driver
monitoring policy
less aggressive why would you always not
keep it at its most aggressive
because then people are just going to
get fatigued from it yes when they get
annoyed
you want them you want you want the
experience to be pleasant
obviously i want the experience to be
pleasant but even just from a straight
up safety perspective
if you alert people when they look
around and they're like
why is this thing alerting me there's
nothing i could possibly hit right now
people will just learn to tune it out
people will just learn to tune it out to
put weights on the steering wheel to do
whatever to overcome it
and remember that you're always part of
this adaptive system so
all i can really say about you know how
this scale is going forward is yeah
something we have to monitor for
we don't know this is a great psychology
experiment at scale like we'll see
yeah it's fascinating track it and
making sure you have a good
understanding of attention is a very key
part of that psychology problem
yeah i think i mean you and i probably
have a different come to it differently
but to me
it's an it's a fascinating psychology
problem to explore something much deeper
than just driving
it's a it's such a nice way to explore
human
attention and human behavior
which is why again we've probably both
criticized
mr elon musk on this one topic from
different
avenues uh so both offline and online i
had little chats with elon and
like i love human beings as a as a
as a computer vision problem as an ai
problem it's fascinating he wasn't so
much interested in that problem
it's like in order to solve driving the
whole point is you want to remove the
human from the picture
and it seems like you can't do that
quite yet eventually yes but
you can't quite do that yet so
this is the moment where and you can't
yet say
i told you so uh to tesla
but it's getting there because i don't
know if you've seen this there's some
reporting that they're in fact starting
to do
drive them off yeah they ship the model
in shadow mode
uh without uh i believe only a visible
light camera it might even be fisheye
it's like a low resolution low
resolution visible light
i mean to be fair that's what we have in
the e on as well our last generation
product
this is the one area where i can say our
hardware's ahead of tesla the rest of
our hardware way way behind but our
driver monitoring camera
do you think uh i think on the
third row tesla podcast or somewhere
else i've heard you say that
obviously eventually they're gonna have
driver monitoring
i think what i've said is elon will
definitely ship driver monitoring before
he ships level
five the beautiful level and i'm willing
to about 10 grand on that
and you put 10 grand on that uh i mean
now i want to take the bat but before
maybe someone would have i should have
got my money
yeah it's an interesting bet i think i
i think you're right i'm actually
on a on a human level because he's been
he's made the decision like he said that
driver monitoring is the wrong way to go
but like you have to think of as a human
as a ceo
i think that's the right thing to say
when like
sometimes you have to say things
publicly they're different than when you
actually believe
because when you're producing a large
number of vehicles
and the decision was made not to include
the camera like what are you supposed to
say yeah
like our cars don't have the thing that
i think is right to have
uh it's an interesting thing but like on
the other side
as a ceo i mean something you could
probably speak to as a leader
i think about me as a human
to publicly change your mind on
something how hard is that
well especially when like
george haws say i told you so
all i will say is i am not a leader and
i am happy to change my mind
um and i think elon will
yeah i do uh i think he'll come up with
a good way to
make it psychologically okay for him
well
it's such an important thing man
especially for first principles thinker
because he made a decision
that driver monitoring is not the right
way to go and i could see that decision
and i could even make that decision like
i was on the fence
too like i'm not driving monitoring
is such an obvious simple solution to
the problem of attention
it's not obvious to me that just by
putting a camera there you solve
things you have to create an
incredible compelling experience just
like you're you're talking about
and i don't know if it's easy to do that
it's not at all easy to do that in fact
i think
so as a creator of a car that's trying
to
create a product that people love which
is what tesla tries to do right
it's not obvious to me that uh you know
as a design decision whether adding a
camera
is a good idea from a safety perspective
either like
in the human factors community everybody
says
that like you should obviously have
driver sensing driver monitoring
but like that
that's like saying it's obvious as
parents you shouldn't let your kids go
out at night
but okay but like
they're still gonna find ways to do
drugs
yeah you have to also be good parents so
like it's it's much more complicated
than just like
you need to have driver monitoring i
totally disagree on
okay if you have a camera there and the
camera's watching the person
but never throws an alert they'll never
think about it
right the the driver monitoring policy
that you choose to how you choose to
communicate with the user is
entirely separate from the data
collection perspective right
right so you know like
there's one thing to say like you know
tell your teenager they can't do
something
there's another thing to like you know
gather the data so you can
make informed decisions that's really
interesting but you have to make that
that's the interesting thing about cars
uh but even true with com ai like you
don't have to
manufacture the thing into the car is
you have to make a decision that
anticipates
the right strategy long term so like you
have to start collecting the data
and start making decisions started it
started it three years ago
i believe that we have the best driver
monitoring solution in the world
um i think that when you compare it to
well supercruise is the only other one
that i really know that shipped
and ours is better what uh
what do you like and not like about
super coos
um i mean i had a few super cruise uh
the
sun would be shining through the window
would blind the camera and it would say
i wasn't paying attention when i was
looking completely straight
i couldn't reset the attention with a
steering wheel touch
and supercrews would disengage like i
was communicating to the car i'm like
look i'm here i'm paying attention why
are you really gonna force me to
disengage and
it did um so it's it's a constant
conversation with the user and yeah
there's no way to ship a system like
this if you can ota
right we're shipping a new one every
month sometimes we balance it with our
users on discord like when sometimes we
make the driver monitoring a little more
aggressive and people complain
sometimes they don't you know we want it
to be as aggressive as possible where
people
don't complain and it doesn't feel
intrusive so being able to update the
system over the air is an essential
component
i mean that's probably to me you
mentioned uh
i mean to me that is the biggest
innovation of tesla
that it it made it people realize that
over-the-air updates
is essential yeah i mean
yeah was that not obvious from the
iphone the iphone was the first real
product that ota
i think was it actually that's that's
brilliant you're right i mean the game
consoles used to not right
the game console is maybe the second
thing that did well i didn't really
think about
one of the amazing features of a
smartphone
isn't just like the touchscreen isn't
the thing
it's the ability to constantly update
gets better it gets better
i love my ios 14 yeah uh
one thing that i probably disagree with
you on on driving monitoring
is you've said that it's easy like i
mean you you tend to say stuff is easy
i'm sure the uh i guess you said it's
easy relative to the
external perception problem
can you elaborate why you think it's
easy feature engineering works
for driver monitoring feature
engineering does not work for the
external
so human faces are not
human faces and the movement of human
faces and head and body
is not as variable as the external
environment is your intuition um
yes and there's another big difference
as well your reliability of a driver
monitoring system
doesn't actually need to be that high
the uncertainty
if you have something that's detecting
whether the human is paying attention it
only works 92
of the time you're still getting almost
all the benefit of that because the
human like you're training the human
yeah right you're you're dealing with a
system that's really helping you out
it's a conversation it's not like the
external thing where
guess what if you swerve into a tree you
swerve into a tree
right like you get no margin for error
there yeah i think that's really well
put i
i i think that's the right exactly the
place
where um where comparing to the external
perception the control problem
driver monitoring is easier because you
know the bar for success is much lower
yeah but i i still think like the human
face
is more complicated actually than the
external environment but for driving you
don't give a damn
i don't need yet i don't need something
i don't need something that complicated
to to to have to communicate the idea
to the human that i want to communicate
which is yo
system might mess up here you got to pay
attention
yeah see that's that's my love and
fascination is the
the human face and it feels like this is
a nice place to um create products that
create an experience in the car
so like it feels like there should be
more
richer experiences in the car
you know like that's an opportunity for
like
something like my eye or just any kind
of system like a tesla or any of the
autonomous vehicle companies
is because software's and there's much
more sensors
and so much is run on software and
you're doing machine learning anyway
there's an opportunity to create totally
new experiences
that we're not even anticipating you
don't think so
now you think it's a box that gets you
from a to b and you want to do it
chill yeah i mean i think as soon as we
get to level three on highways okay
enjoy your candy crush
enjoy your hulu enjoy your you know
whatever whatever sure you get this you
can look at screens basically
versus right now what do you have music
and audio books so level three is where
you can kind of disengage in stretches
of time
well you think level three is possible
like on the highway going for 100 miles
and you can just
go to sleep oh yeah uh sleep
so again i think it's really all on a
spectrum
i think that being able to use your
phone while you're on the highway
and like this all being okay and being
aware that the car might alert you and
you have five seconds to basically
the five second things that you think is
possible yeah i think it is oh yeah
not in all scenarios right some
scenarios it's not
you